[Music]
in this session we'll be taking you
through
three short demos that will help you
when working with google cloud's
serverless technologies we'll be showing
you how to use bill packs to build
containers
how to use cloud code to deploy cloud
run services and how to use visual
studio code to debug cloud functions
hi i'm katie and in the next few minutes
you'll see that building containers
isn't that scary when working with
serverless
you have to work with a packaging
concept known as a container image
container images or just containers are
just that
they contain all the elements required
to run an application
they allow an app to run in isolation
and for many apps on the same
infrastructure
to run without interfering with each
other there are multiple ways that you
can make these containers
the most popular way is to write a list
of instructions in a docker file
that are used to build your image you
start
from a base image you copy files from
your local file system
into the image you then run commands
such as installing dependencies
and you then define a entry point a
command that is run when you start your
container
this is a very common template for
docker files
so much so that there are now automation
tools that presume this format
with build packs you don't have to write
a docker file
google cloud build packs are built onto
buildpack standard
automatically detecting which
programming language you're using
and running the steps common for that
language and make a container ready to
be used across
many google cloud products in fact most
cloud functions deployed in the last
year
have been using buildpacks behind the
scenes with help from the functions
framework
sarah will be discussing more about
cloud functions later in this demo
let me give you an example of the power
of buildbacks
when developing a javascript app on your
computer you would
install node write your app and create a
package.json file where you define your
dependencies in your star command you
would then install the dependencies that
you've defined
and then you would run the start command
you've defined which will start your web
app
if you were to write a docker file you
would do the same thing
you'd start with a node-based image
which has node already installed for you
you then copy your files then install
your dependencies
and when the container is invoked run
your web server
build packs do the same thing when they
detect a node app
it will detect that you need the node
runtime and set that up for you
copy your files into the image install
your dependencies
and then set the entry point to run when
your container is started
however for some programming languages
there may not be
one way to do things for example when
developing in python
installing dependencies is very standard
but how to start your web server is not
buildpack doesn't know what to do in
this situation and will return an error
if you try to build your container
without defining your entry point
in this case buildpax needs one added
file
a proc file or process file that defines
what you want the web process to be
adding this file to your code base tells
build packs what you want to run
to start your web server it's picked up
by the build process and will be run
when you start your container
no matter the language you use you can
set your own proc file
for instance the java build pack doesn't
require a proc file but you can still
define one
defining a proc file will override the
default command
run to start your container you can also
override other default functionality
with environment variables
take a look at the documentation over on
github for more information
after installing the pack command tool
you can build your own containers on
your local machine if you have docker
installed
or you can submit the build to google
cloud build which will run
pac for you making your containers
available in the google container
registry
bill packs are available for javascript
python
java.net and go you can read more about
this on our blog
and try out some sample applications
over on github
but as for deploying your containers let
me hand you over to abby
why can't you just show the build packs
was awesome but what's next
hi i'm abby and i'm going to show how
one dev tool makes containerizing
and deploying your app to cloud run one
of google cloud servo's offerings
easy but first what is cloud run
where am i deploying to cloudrun is a
fully managed
serverless container based platform it
lets you deploy stateless
http containers deploying cloud run
services is super fast
and i'll show you my demo in a bit you
also get the flexibility of configuring
your own custom domains
cloudrun supports custom binaries so any
language or library is fair game
and because it's container based cloud
run services are portable
but one of the biggest appeals of cloud
run is its ability to scale down to zero
when no traffic is hitting your service
cloud code can help you out on your
serverless journey right from your ide
cloud code is an ide plug-in that
automates development workflows for
cloud-based applications
written in python go java node.js
and c-sharp if you develop with vs code
or one of these jetbrains ides cloud
code can help you out
cloud code supports a number of
development flows for cloud run
first it helps you ramp up fast with
integrated samples
when it comes to building and deploying
container images cloud cloudcover merges
the two steps into just a couple clicks
and regarding debugging cloud code lets
you debug your service in a local
emulated production-like environment
cloudcode also has a feature where
after hitting save your code is
automatically built and deployed again
speeding up your inner dev loop and
finally you can manage your cloud run
services
right from your ide that's a quick look
at cloud run and cloud code
but how about a demo with cloud code
i'll create
a starter cloud run service run it
locally
on the cloud run emulator and finally
deploy it to cloud run
all from my ide so i'm using vs code for
this demo
i already have the cloud code extension
installed from the vs code marketplace
you can tell because i have this stack
of four icons seen to the left and a
cloud code button
down here i'll create a new project
using one of cloud code's integrated
samples
first i'll hit the cloud code button
then select a new application
and then cloud run application cloud
code has samples for the supported
languages i mentioned
for this demo i'll create a node.js
hello world service
i now have a node.js cloudrun service
that's ready to be deployed
before deploying to cloudrun i want to
make sure everything works locally
first though to do that i'll build and
deploy locally to cloud code's cloud run
emulator
it emulates production so there aren't
any surprises once i actually do deploy
to production
i'll hit the cloud code button again and
select run on cloud run
emulator
now i'll configure my local deployment
for my builder
i'll switch from docker to build pack so
that i don't worry about a dockerfile
under advanced service settings i can
set container properties like cpu
allocation
environment variables and connect to
cloud sql databases
looks good now i'll hit run
cloud code is now handling all the
commands for building and deploying to
the emulator
once that's done i can open this link
and there it is my node.js service built
with build packs running locally in my
emulator
since everything is looking great i'll
skip debugging things and jump
right to deploying this service to
cloudrun
i will hit the cloud code button one
more time and select
deploy to cloud run
this all looks very similar to deploying
to the local emulator
since i'm creating a new service i'll
leave this box alone
my deployment platform will be cloud run
and i'll once again switch my builder
to build packs
and that'll hit deploy i'll click the
link to my deployed service
and this is my node.js service deployed
to cloud run
now anyone can access it that was a look
at how cloud code makes building
containers with build packs
and deploying the cloud run easy join
the cloud code channel on the google
cloud platform community slack
to stay up to date on announcements and
ask questions
now i'll hand it off to sarah who's
going to cover local debugging of cloud
functions
thanks abby for showing us how you can
use cloud run within visual studio code
hi
i'm sarah and i'm going to be your guide
to another serverless compute offering
called
cloud functions cloud functions allows
you to run
small snippets of code in an
event-driven way
so let's see cloud functions in action
suppose you have previously deployed a
cloud function that receives data
from an iot sensor that reports about
whether the temperature
is too hot or it's okay
and let's say that you want to verify
your function is working properly
in production you can use visual studio
code
in the terminal window to send curl
commands
so here we can send a curl command to
verify
whether the temperature is too hot and
your choice if this is celsius or
fahrenheit
and here when we send this command we
see that it reports back to hot
we could also test the okay condition
and we see it comes back okay but what
if you forget to send a paylet
notice that this also says too hot you
have found a bug
now you want to fix and verify this
locally before you push to production
and to do that you can use the functions
framework
so the functions framework is an open
source functions as a service framework
written by the google cloud functions
team
and the functions framework is available
in go java php
python ruby and net and here you can see
that has been successfully
installed and we can also use visual
studio code's
built-in debugging tools for node
to divide guard file function because
we're in the debugging session we want
to hit continue to allow the function to
just
finish gracefully and now we can go to
the first terminal window
and stop serving the function
let's say that the specification says in
the unlikely event
that a payload is not sent
we want to throw an exception so i'll
add the code now
to throw the exception and let's test
this
but this time i am not going to use the
inspect flag
so this will not start a debugging
session and you'll notice
that visual studio stays in the blue
status bar and let's invoke it
the function and we see the correct
behavior the exception is thrown
and is also locked
now you are ready to deploy your
function to production
if you would like to learn more about
how to do this demo yourself
you can check out the corresponding code
lab for this talk
thank you for attending our session you
saw how to use build packs to build
containers
how to use cloud code to deploy cloud
run services
and how to use visual studio code to
debug cloud functions
if you want to learn more you can visit
our github repo for bill packs
check out the cloud code channel in the
google cloud platform community slack
and follow along debugging cloud
functions in our codelab
thank you for attending this session and
have a great google i o
[Music]